hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update if you're an xbox one owner
who has been upset about the indefinite
delay of spider-man 2 on your xbox
you're in luck because the game has just
kind of come out today it seems the Xbox
one version of the game was postponed by
Activision last week but us customers
are currently able to purchase download
and play the game via the xbox games
marketplace priced at 59 99 the game is
apparently working just fine although
perhaps there are undiscovered bugs that
cause the game to be delayed no reasons
for the delay were given but Activision
said previously we are working with
Microsoft in an effort to release the
amazing spider-man 2 video game on xbox
one the game's developer be Knox wrote
on Twitter regarding the former delay we
know it's frustrating for all of you as
it is for our programming team who
worked hard on the game so it's kind of
weird that the game was just released on
xbox one with no further comment from
Activision and it's unclear whether or
how long it's going to stay up there but
for more details on spider-man 2 and
Xbox one be sure to stay tuned to
gamespot